si je vous disais que le plastique c'est
bon pour l'environnement ça a permis de
remplacer des matériaux comprenez
ailleurs comme les métaux le bois la
laine et même le cul et figueras au
plastique on a des véhicules plus légers
des maisons mieux isoler et des aliments
qui se conservent plus longtemps avec
ans capitaine c'est vrai qu'on a oublié
que le plastique des avantages parce
qu'il est surtout un énorme défaut si
rien n'est fait le poids du déchet
plastique va dépasser celui des poissons
d'ici 2050 c'est qu'après l'avoir
utilisé on sait plus trop quoi en faire
et en général ça se termine plutôt mal
quand on parle des places et que sa
venue facilement un débat émotif à
savoir son époux contre les places et on
doit remplacer le plastique remplacer le
plastique mais par quoi je pense c'est
ça la vraie question qui se pose d'année
le plastique c'est pas vraiment une
solution viable
leurs visages sont bêtes peu connu mais
quand croque danone ou nestlé problème
de sauver le monde sait sur qui compte
ils font partie d'une nouvelle
génération de recycleur cherche à
prolonger le cycle de vie du clas tcsa
le coeur de ce qu'ont fait finalement si
on a un produit on les aime comme en
fait pour pouvoir le réutiliser
indéfiniment ces jours ci c'est presque
étonnant d'entendre quelqu'un parler de
son amour du plastique mais il faut se
rappeler que quand le plastiki est
inventé c'est révolutionnaire
joe cole est fait madame roux d'un
renard pour les moteurs à des tas d
pouvait lui donner n'importe quelle
forme n'importe quelle couleur
[Musique]
on s'est mis à faire un peu tout et
n'importe quoi des choses utiles et donc
est un peu moins et on le voit dans les
chiffres la production augmenter de
façon exponentielle et même son aimant
bien que la courbe se met à faire ça
avec la population qui augmente et qui
s'enrichit la demande risque plutôt de
tripler d'ici 2050
on a donc tout intérêt à le recycler
sauf que c'est pas comme avec
l'aluminium blanc ou en groupe on peut
prendre des vieilles cannes est pour en
faire des nouvelles à peu près à
l'infini avec le plastique c'est pas mal
plus compliqué non seulement il y en a
partout mais il en existe des dizaines
de variétés
parmi elles il ya les fameux logo de un
à sept convois sur certains produits
comme les emballages
est-ce qu'on peut mettre dans le bac
varie d'une ville à l'autre
et quand les plastiques qui arrive dans
un centre de tri ils sont pêle mêle avec
tout le reste il faut tout trier le
mieux possible et le plus vite possible
et ça se fait pas à la main c'est un
vrai labyrinthe avec des appareils de
plus en plus sophistiqués entre autres à
cause du plastique et à la priorité
c'est de récupérer les plastiques qui
ont une bonne valeur de revente comme le
numéro 1 le pays hôte et celui des
bouteilles d'eau ou encore le numéro 2
des contenants de détergents les autres
se retrouvent souvent dans des ballots
de plastique mixte en général on les
exportateurs dans l'espoir que quelqu'un
vole et recyclés et c'est souvent ces
plastiques là qu'on voit dans les
reportages l'apache certains plastiques
qui sera sec bien consentement c'est du
recyclage mécanique ça consiste à laver
sécher royer qui sera fond le tout pour
y donner une nouvelle forme
sauf que si vous voulez refaire des
bouteilles ça prend un tri vraiment
exceptionnel pour avoir dupé été
recyclés transparent et souvent des
impuretés et avec chaque recyclage et
devient plus friable la majorité du psg
est donc transformé en fibres
synthétiques comme des tapis ou des
vêtements en polyester évidemment mieux
que de les fabriquer à partir de pétrole
brut
mais ce sont des produits qui sont pas
recyclables 9h35
c'est de prendre un produit de très
haute qualité de le transformer dans un
produit de moins bonne qualité
la technologie loup puis ça permet
d'aller de l'autre sens parce que loupe
fait partie de la poignée d'entreprises
qui prépare une révolution c'est mauvais
cyclage chimiques
on peut faire l'analogie avec un gâteau
le reste l'âge actuel ça consiste à le
broyer et à réutiliser les miettes pour
faire un nom devait faire comme un
biscuit ou un pudding affleurait ce
clash chimiques c'est comme si on
faisait la recette à l'envers pour
retrouver les oeufs le lait la farine
n'a pas manqué d'humour plat résultats
avec des ingrédients recyclé on peut
fabriquer du plastique neuf la plus
haute qualité
on peut donc à refaire des bouteilles
transparentes et le plus beau là dedans
c'est qu'on peut récupérer les
ingrédients peu importe la recette de
départ parce que le logo numéro un
ça veut pas dire que c'est du pt pu
souvent plastique vous convenez en
différant addictif pour changer sa
couleur ou sa texture la multiplication
des recettes
ça complique encore plus leur recyclage
mécanique mais avec le recyclage
chimiques
on contourne le problème chez look par
exemple en utilisant un solvant on
sépare les deux ingrédients qui servent
à faire du pays était de toutes les
impuretés comme les étiquettes ou les
colonnes le procédé de loupe fonctionne
seulement avec le plastique numéro 1
pour le numéro 6 c'est pire wave qui a
trouvé la solution à un très gros
problème dans le monde la marche i du
policier 25 millions de tonnes et 25
millions de tonnes de polystyrène comme
la mousse les gobelets et les podiums go
ça prend de la place
c'est assez pour recouvrir l'île de
montréal au complet sur deux mètres de
haut et on en ressent très peu chez
pierrot et vous si on mise sur le
recyclage chimiques
ça c'est la surpuissance de notre
procédé mail approche est complètement
différent et 100 fois l'absence de
grandes maisons
l'équipe a mis dix ans à dompter sa
puissance pour briser les liens
chimiques à l'intérieur du polystyrène
ce qu'on récupère c'est l'ingrédient de
base pour refaire du polystyrène vierge
l'industrie du plastique peut donc s'en
servir au lieu de repartir à zéro avec
du pétrole et du gaz naturel
et s'il ya un seul chef à retenir ses 6
% chaque année 6 % du pétrole dans le
monde sert à fabriquer du plastique
c'est à peu près autant de pétrole que
pour tous les déplacements en avion et
la quasi-totalité du plastique va finir
soit dans un dépotoir dans un
incinérateur ou carrément dans la nature
et l'année d'après on recommence la
grande promesse du recyclage chimiques
c'est de rendre ce modèle linéaire là un
peu plus circulaire quitte à payer un
peu plus cher pour du plastique un peu
plus vers la pression populaire c'est
quelque chose qui fait
évidemment bouger les marques pour nous
c'est important parce que ça ça me met
de la valeur le travail qu'on fait je
pense sincèrement que l'école et
certains pays va commencer à dieu vous
devez mettre 35 40 50 cent pour cent de
matières recyclées dans leur beauté
parce qu'il existe une solution et ça
c'est l'avenir chez pierrot wave comme
chez loupé la technologie est prête à
être déployée à grande échelle et les
deux ont des ententes avec des géants de
la pétrochimie et d'alimentaire le
risque chimique à un bel avenir devant
lui mais ça va pas régler tous les
problèmes du plastique
il ya plein de pays qui ont même pas de
système de collecte 20 d'emballage aussi
qu'ils sont pas conçus pour être
recyclés et puis avouons le il ya aussi
beaucoup de plastique dont on pourrait
tout simplement se passait il ya un
monsieur le filet et en 1869 65 à peu
près avait besoin d'une balle de billard
il a trouvé le moyen tous dans la salle
hulot pour en faire une balle de billard
parce qu'ils vont te d'ivoire alors en
faisant tous ces mélanges du film a
ouvert le monde à ce qu'on appelle les
plastiques
[Musique]